is elon musk
one dumb tweet away from being suspended
and permanently suspended from twitter
that's the question
okay i'm gonna you want an answer right
i'm curious i'm gonna say no
i would say he's got more leash than one
dumb because he's good for twitter
all right every time you hear about elon
being in the news it's because of
twitter
trump was bad for twitter for twitter
business-wise
okay i'm just answering the question you
asked i do not believe he's
one dumb tweet away i think he's earned
enough equity
where he could have two or three he's
not dumb enough to do it or he has the
saint card that he'll be forgiven
both he's clearly not that stupid where
he's gonna do something like that can i
make two other points about musk real
quickly number one
um it was 11 degrees in moscow yesterday
and eight degrees in austin texas so
maybe he wants to move there who knows
that's why he called putin
number two though seriously you know you
think about social media influencers or
people that have
influence that have a following that
people respond to what do brands do for
them they bring them money so they post
right it pushes the brand makes them
money elon musk
is immune to that like an insider
trading situation hey can you do one
tweet on my company it'll blow up
he's already the richest person in the
world there's no financial benefit for
him
individually to ever do something
because you'd always ask yourself
when you have that much power and that
much sway and so many disciples that
will do
whatever you say to do with a five-word
tweet are you susceptible to being
bribed
insider trading taking something that's
unethical or doing something and using
that power in a negative way he could
never do it for financial reasons
because he doesn't have to he's already
the richest guy in the world
would twitter ever ban elon musk that's
the question
yes right because it's a two it's a
two-prong question
one is would he ever post something
dumb enough that would jeopardize him
staying on
twitter and number two would twitter
ever have the audacity
to say we were permanently banned i
think if he does do that just going on
track record
i'm gonna have to say yes why would i
say yes number one
he's done some stupid stuff that has
moved uh
look for all the kudos that were given
elon musk he's also done stuff that has
hurt the brand and the stock
like i could see either the you know
board of directors or even self-imposed
being like dude put down the twitter for
a second i could see that
you he went on joe rogan podcast smoked
a blunt that did not help the company
i could see that thing and then if
twitter has any track record
for silencing voices especially more
conservative voices and i i
politically i think that elon musk is
center right
right i don't know how far right he is
he's certainly not a leftist or anything
like that i think he's more center-right
he's obviously a capitalist
for sure can i see him saying something
so outlandish or so from his perspective
what he thinks is right but you know the
leftist whoever's controlling twitter
thinks is wrong i think it could happen
uh do i want it to happen
am i rooting for elon musk am i rooting
for his companies and you know space
travel hell yeah
but based on track record things that
he's said and what twitter has done or
social media
has done to write leaning voices it's
possible yes
do you what do you think so so here's
how i process this here's how i process
this
when you get a person like that that is
that eccentric mind non-stop working
you know take mark take a howard hughes
okay
and take tony stark the character howard
he was real character
tony stark you know fictional character
iron man right
robert downey jr okay there was a part
about
the girl that plays in iron man that
dude just shut your mouth and stay down
here don't say anything to the media i
don't know if you remember that
relationship
yes yes well she's kind of like dude
just don't say anything you get in front
of mike's like ah screw it here's what
i'm doing you know what we're going
dude just be quiet right does musk like
is musk the kind of guy that behind
closed doors
you tell him not to say something he
won't say it i don't think so
i think if musk wants to say something
he'll say now let me flip it
so so i do think there's an element of
that let me go to a different direction
howard hughes is there an element of a
musk that he could get
bored out of his mind that he may want
to do something crazy i don't know
you know he he's gonna in his brain like
he sees things that the world doesn't
see yeah he sees the world from a
different
place but i have a neural link but i'll
give you the last one here i'll give you
the last one here why i don't think it
would happen
here's what i don't think it would
happen i don't think it would happen
because he came from the paypal mafia
community
and that entire community is all
connected and they all work together
yeah and somebody would make the call
and say elon just so you know you're
gonna get a slap and you're gonna have
to suspend you for like a day or
something but you're gonna get back on
just
don't do that again bro like you ain't
helping yourself okay you know and then
he's gonna go back to what he's doing
because he came from that yeah so where
are we going with this
we're going with uh what do you call it
uh
people that have been suspended on
twitter so
trump he got banned from twitter right
do you give credit to some of these guys
elon musk for knowing how to build
allies i don't know
because a part of this is also having
allies did trump have any allies
in silicon valley i don't know if he had
any allies peter too
no one public though peter thiel is not
he's influential but he's not as
influential as some of these other guys
that are the
you know dorsey some of these zuck some
of these guys right okay
he got close to tim cook if you remember
tim cook came in but does tim cook have
more power than
zuck does tim cook have more power than
uh what do you call it
dorsey when it comes down to i think so
when it comes down to influence i don't
think so because
trump doesn't need an app like
apple's power is in the app like we will
not
let your app be there but trump's power
is he needs to communicate through what
twitter or a facebook which is a
platform apple's not a platform
apple's a company that access those
platforms through your phone
yeah but but that means apple would have
to ban facebook and they're never going
to do that
apple would have to bl pan so they are
in a little tip right now they are but
it's different to
communicate there's no way apple would
uh if they banned facebook it would be
insane if they did that yeah trump's a
bit of an outlier though
because we're talking about i mean what
they said he did
starting an insurrection and a riot in
that and there's there's a difference
between that
and whatever musk or anybody else is
even capable of tweeting right i mean
something that ended up with the capital
being stormed is a little bit different
you know
he's got so much influence musk i think
twitter's got to be afraid of him number
one and number two couldn't he just snap
them up or put them out if he wanted to
or really seriously hurt them
if they did something to him these are
200 billion twitter's a 40 billion
dollar company i want to come and buy
you and you're out
you know but but dorsey is a guy that
wanted to be a fashion designer right
so dorsey is also not the guy that
wanted to be a billionaire like dorsey
doesn't give a crap about being a
billionaire like
dorsey's not the you know the the
billionaire dorsey
he's growing a homeless man he's not
he's not at all the guy that's like the
typical
i'm gonna go take over the world that's
not that's not the worst you're saying
like an accidental billionaire
you know he's he's actually a i think
deep down inside has an
activist bone to him and he really
disagrees with some of the philosophical
views even if it costs him five billion
dollars or two
i don't think he cares he has principles
values and principles i think he's a
true believer
i don't in what he believes in okay and
what he i think he's a true believer in
what he believes in
let me let me even if it costs some
money let me circle back to the trump
and
your initial question you know allies
allies
the problem with trump is by the way if
you're enjoying the dialogue with the
way it's going on the podcast with the
three of us here today
and this is your first time joining us
on the podcast you have no clue what's
going on but you're liking it smash that
subscribe button
uh once we get to 100 000 subs we're
considering doing this possibly three
times a week
once it gets to a hundred thousand we
got 53 000 more to go but go ahead you
were talking about allies
shout out to martin mirage he says the
paypal mafia
over the soyboy mafia i don't know about
that i don't know about that these days
adam's wearing those shorts they'll
retreat yeah they'll run away good
points submit so if somebody post a
picture of his
shorts or let's get that out there guys
go ahead let's get that the shorts he
wore when he
might ban that we almost got kicked
that's the shorts he was wearing yeah
the old school old school 50s nba 60s
nba
george michael all the way to the top
so back to allies back to allies and
this is like
i can't believe i'm referencing
something my mom would tell me in
kindergarten but she would tell me
um with the voice with the voice i'll do
it she would say
um to have a friend you need to be a
friend
to have a friend you need to be a friend
i was like all right like let me i gotta
i gotta be a friend to you if you're
gonna be a friend of me
the problem with trump is he uses you he
chews you up and he spits you out
anyone who's left that um
team or whatever you want to call it the
cabinet in
out in out any i mean we can go down the
list i'm just gonna you know
you know go off the off the cuff here
rex tillerson was there
does not like him now anthony scaramucci
your boy was there for like a hot seven
days
out um what's my uh general kelly
in out i mean omarosa omarosa in out
you don't hear those stories about elon
musk you don't hear oh
i worked with elon and he was a piece of
[ __ ] and he's fired me
you don't hear those you hear those
about trump so
you talked about allies i think to your
credit to your point
trump uh musk makes a call to whether
it's a dorsey whether it's a zuk whether
it's a
cook whether it's a penny off whatever
it is
and says look man this that is that
let's work it out
there you know intermediaries takes a
friend to be a friend i think he's got
true allies
where trump is legacy is he'll use you
abuse you and then spit you out
i mean listen there's uh there's proof
to show that that did take place and
there's proof on elan as well
elon's created a lot of enemies in a
different way steve jobs had a lot of
enemies where uh
i don't know if you've ever read the
book accidental millionaire not
accidental billionaire accidental
millionaire was written in the 80s maybe
early 90s
it's a fascinating book but you know
what the book it's actually written in
95 i believe
not the millionaire next door no
different accidental millionaire
can you pull up accidental millionaires
just apple's old logo the rainbow logo
book accidental millionaire book i want
to know when it was written
nice oh shout out to kai's spelling
great
go to go to amazon go to amazon right
there
no go to amazon yeah click on that there
you go
see if it comes that's not the book
though uh that you see that's the thing
no one can find a book
go back oh there it is that's the one
look how many reviews it's got
eight reviews lee butcher okay what's
going on here this book go down to see
when this book came out go down i mean
who reads this book only
1987 this book came out the entire book
is trashing jobs
no seriously the entire book is trashing
jobs who was it written by
by people that got fired by him or let
go by him so
jobs and trump had a little bit of a
think and you know jobs was like in the
middle of
if musk is here trump is your jobs was
here because jobs had a little bit of
trump going on in them as well
but can you can you tell me when did
twitter come out
when did twitter come out kai exactly
when the twitter comes out 607.
because the question is going to follow
up with when did twitter start
what year oh six okay when did
twitter first permanently ban its first
user oh
good question o6 they got started when
do you think was the first time they
permanently
banned you i'd love to get our audience
i'm curious let's get the audience here
don't google it don't be that guy that
googles it don't do it
oh i got the right answer like who do
you think it is yeah when do you think
the first time not the first person but
first time they permanently banned
somebody
isn't the first time the first person
yeah but not the name i'm not looking
for the name
of the next year because or the right
way soon so you're saying oh seven
within a year just because someone's
gonna do something so stupid you got it
what would you say take the other side
of that i think it's like more recent
history i think
it's like 2014.
okay so you're saying eight years later
uh kai do you already know the answer to
this question so i'm not gonna ask you
paul when do you think was the first
time twitter after being around 2006
when is the first time they banned
somebody
you know i'm going to go with 2009.
okay by the way paul wins because it's
2010. okay
it's december 8th 2010. they banned
operation
payback handle a non-underscore
operation anonymous hackath hacktivist
campaign in support of online piracy and
wikileaks
permanently banned okay so that's why
they banned him the next one is courtney
love
january 2011. yes courtney leftist
yes courtney love american musician and
actress was banned
permanently original account days after
fashion designer don
uh filed a defamation suit against love
over tweets made on march 17
29 2009 it was the first high-profile
defamation trial over celebrity comments
on twitter wow
love now uses a different account
courtney she's on
back on but her first hand and behaving
and behaving but the first one was gone
so
then it's another guy that happens in
2011 a norwegian
far-right terrorist no joke and
perpetrator
2011 norway attacks and how do you say
anders
berg is that the guy that went to the
summer camp
yes his account was hacked by that she
said they would oh
god okay so so there you go some names
that they have obviously
anonymous i don't know if you remember
anonymous used to do those videos before
with the mask
remember they used to be big everybody
used to follow
yeah you don't see a lot of them now and
then uh hamas was taken out in 2014.
phil madison since the
palestinian uh yeah exactly military
wing of hamas
is ad din al hassan brigades
was taken down and he got a bunch of
different names that they're going
through right so so
you know pewdiepie was temporarily
suspended for being pretending to be a
member of isil
what i mean you have to be a fool to do
that but the pewdiepie 100 million
subscriber acted like he was a member of
isil yeah obviously you're going to get
taken down for that
and then jack dorsey was taken down
november 2016. after restoring his
account dorsey tweeted the suspension
was due to an internal mistake
the founder and ceo i bet you one of his
own employees played a joke on him
suspended and that's a great story so
anyways then you got a bunch of
different stories on what it is right i
mean you got a bunch of different
stories they can go through on who it is
roger stone got banned permanent october
2017.
[Music]
uh uh so so the the the the names you're
looking at
are relatively reasonable candace owns
got
temporary band august 5th 2018.
uh you got a sabo was permanently banned
street
artist uh chris paronto was temporary
banned
okay september 8 september 10 2018
using the words [ __ ] in a hashtag
uh he says you're an idiot and he uses a
line from the movie
uh uh tropic thunder never go
full [ __ ] yeah that's so the hashtag
it was temporary
everybody know that everybody knows
james woods who if you don't know james
woods is a big twitter user
anything with infowars by the way look
at this it's like 15 accounts they took
down
james was permanent no he's not he came
back it was temporary he came back
i loved him yeah you know and you got a
bunch of different names
by the way james woods was temporary uh
banned a few times it's not just once
that he went through it and then you
lead to trump and then now you got
you know katie hopkins that is
permanently banned that if you guys know
katie topkins is candace owns a couple
times and
recently
charlie kirk temporary david ike
permanently
and you got don bongino temporarily
michael flynn permanently
sydney powell jim watkins ron watkins
all permanently do you
think there is a trend of consistency or
extremes
thoughts you know what i i'm going to
just be a rational human being here for
a couple seconds and i think it's
consistent
i think whenever you do something you
got to know what the rules are and if
you want to play with fire you can get
burned okay
so i don't have a big problem with it
it's a huge platform they're going to
have to police it some way
and if there's people doing things that
they shouldn't be doing now you don't
want
just immediately this is company policy
anybody
that thinks a certain way has no chance
to proclaim their voice on our platform
you don't want that obviously but from
what you just read
it seems like they've done something to
probably deserve it
yeah i thought we were it was going to
be a list of conservative names i didn't
think it was a going to go back this far
to
courtney loves of the world i just want
a big time rapper talib quali
i saw him on the list a few times
permanent ban i thought this was going
to be a list of
right-leaning conservative voices oh
they're silenced in the right
they want to they don't want to hear the
truth i thought that that's where this
was going
but in actuality they just want
truth and not misinformation i don't
think it's
truth i don't think it's truth because
you have to be careful when you say
truth
is it your truth my truth some things as
opinions they don't want
to be blatant lies or manufacturing then
you would take
30 of your guys out i mean you if you if
it's blatant lies you could take 30
of the guys out i think what they're
looking for is is
insinuating or trying to
create fights or you know getting
excitement
and yeah that that that's what you're
that's what you got to be careful with
you know
and some of them is definition of carry
you go after somebody too hard you know
hey what are you doing like
you can't do this you just can't do
things like that um
but uh yeah i mean i don't know look
there's there's a community that says
you they're absolutely targeting and
there's a community that says they're
not targeting
if you look at the list of names that
you're looking at here i think there's a
level of consistency
on what's going on here with twitter so
it's not political
it's just guidelines whether you're left
right
i don't know about permanently banning a
president is the right thing to do i
don't
know if permanently banning good you
know what i would have done here's what
i would have done
look you like for example we have guys
that sell insurance
and insurance you advance right meaning
i give you 100 advance okay you
get a 200 month policy typically
insurance companies will advance you
six months nine months ten months twelve
months so if i do two hundred dollars a
month twenty four hundred dollars says
the target premium
i give you twenty four hundred dollars
up front you're at 50 you make 1200
bucks okay that's insurance that's how
it
allows insurance guys to stick around
because they're making money
up front but if your quality of business
sucks
we take that away so you get a 200 check
from a client then we only pay you as
earns which means what
you cut a 200 check you get 50 of what
that 200
which is what 100 bucks you'll get the
other 200 next month
and it goes as earned i would have done
of your tweets have to go through
screening process
approved goes out for six to twelve
months until we feel confident and then
we'll take it down that's what i would
have done i would have gone
full out the direction that went and
guess what if 100 percent
and some people say well we don't have
that kind of staff it's one person
they do this with it's a president you
make an exception you make
one person's job is to sit there with a
committee of four other people two of
them are conservative two of them are
liberals one of them is independent
so i would do it too liberal two
conservative one independent hash it out
this one can't go up this word needs to
change and then you have an approval
process
are you comfortable changing this word
or this tweet can not go out
that the trump did tweet a lot though
there'd be a lot of a lot of tweets to
look at it but you got five employees
that handle one account that's the
president that's not a big deal right
five times a hundred grand half a month
there's a lot of people that wished
that trump had some sort of vetting
process in his four years of
freedom of change look i think they're
smart i think the smart move for twitter
say it's six months banned
then you can try to come back and if you
misstep you're gone for good because
look at the publicity they'd get in six
months everybody's waiting for that
first tweet
what's he gonna say yeah so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye